[Musique]
je m'appelle laurence baby j'ai 53 ans
et j'ai fondé marquise hébergeurs en
[Musique]
c'est une activité en deux parties une
activité qui concerne le métier de
tapissier décorateur donc fauteuil
réflexion fauteuil de siège de canapés
et aussi tout ce qui est des cordes
fenêtre voilages rideaux aux stores
bateau par exemple et l'autre partie
c'est une
une activité de décoration d'intérieur
avec du conseil autour de la vente de
peintures et de papier peint souvent et
on refait le fauteuil à partir de sa
carcasse à ce qu'on appelle la carcasse
et le fus donc on leur semble on leur
met avec du ressort
là vous pouvez voir derrière moi il doit
y avoir un fauteuil avec du sel en crin
donc ça c'est une garniture dit
traditionnel pique et ensuite avec de
lambour sûrs
notre projet phare c'est d'avoir
travaillé avec le château de breteuil
depuis 2016 où on a eu quand même 80
mètres de tissu
des échafaudages pour poser les rideaux
seront était à 6 mètres sous plafond et
peu près 20 kg par pardo uniquement
[Musique]
l'aventuré entreprenariale pour moi
c'était la possibilité d'être
indépendante d'être autonome et de prime
abord c'était la possibilité de redonner
une deuxième vie à des objets qui
m'était confiée la possibilité de
recréer des sièges et de les rendre aux
clients en voyant voilà leurs yeux qui
pétillent et d'autre part de faire aussi
un petit peu de création avec par
exemple cette ce petit fauteuil qui a
été trouvés dans les poubelles et qu'on
va remettre en état et qui pourra même
être mis à la vente par la suite et
d'autre part le faire savoir c'est la
possibilité de passer sa compétence à un
jeune qui est motivé